here we go we have this tweet from drama
alert former U.S intelligence agent
David grush confirms under oath that
aliens exist okay
technically he did in the context of the
question asked and how he answered he
did but I'm willing to bet he's that a
game is being played to distract us from
the hunter Biden news about tax
avoidance uh tax evasion and other
illicit business deals failure to
register as a foreign agent all of a
sudden we get this story which seems to
be nonsense but in the rare uh look it's
going to be really funny in 50 years
when they're like humans made uh contact
with aliens you know in the 30s or
whatever and it was revealed to the
public in 2023 but no one cared so okay
we'll we'll talk about this because it
may be big news but let me play this
video for you we have a rep Nancy mace
talking uh asking this question and it
is a is a good question where's our
audience our audio good let me get the
audio up and then here we go if you
believe we have crashed craft uh stated
earlier do we have the bodies of the
pilots who piloted this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program if you believe okay
I'm just I'll say it again I said in the
intro to the show
piloted first of all she said pilots and
it seems like it kind of weasled past it
yes we were she says did you find piles
he goes we've recovered biologics yeah
does that mean we recovered the pilots
or does it mean like there was a leaf in
the vessel
he did not say look I'm sorry man if
you're trying to confirm the ages of
aliens you need to look Nancy mace in
the eyes and say ma'am the vehicles or
craft whatever they may be appear to
have originated not on this Earth
Technology we don't understand and
whatever creature or entity was inside
of it is unrecognizable to us then I'd
be like whoa even then I'd be like what
was it burned okay
non-human entity someone posted a
picture of an ant riding a leaf
so remember Barack Obama when he said he
didn't know when life began that that
was above his pay grade we don't even
know in human we don't even know when
human beings are yeah so there would be
a non-human biologic it beats us right
so he's saying they may have found a
fetus in the spaceship and they're alive
it's not a human that is a theory Tim
that is a theory I'm so jaded on all of
the the recent alien stuff so I'm just
not it's not fun anymore the god like I
don't think they're I don't buy anything
the government says anyways why am I
gonna believe this we've had in intense
advancements in microelectronics and in
metamaterials that are lighter than a
lot of them are lighter than air some of
them are we also have talking plasma
like Laser Technology that can
triangulate into points in the
atmosphere and create a plasma ball you
can move around rapidly on a radar make
it look like it's some crazy craft it's
just it's too much obvious advancements
to start pretending now 100 years later
that we're finally in touch with aliens
they try to pull this over on people in
the 40s 1940s with Roswell they said it
was a hot air balloon they said it was
balloon then all of a sudden they're
like oh no it wasn't a balloon it was a
it was an alien craft everybody what was
that what was the dog's name Leica
a non-human pilot of us of an off-earth
vehicle pilate is a that's very generous
I was a pilot very dog hit buttons it
could also be they store data in DNA um
so it could have been like a computer an
onboard computer piloting it that had
its data stored in DNA which is a
biologic it's an organic
uh carbon-based look off-earth
technology could literally mean a
balloon it's what's off the Earth you
know what I mean yeah it's manipulative
manipulative language and the dude
didn't bring any real evidence and he
and he danced around the issues but I
will add he did he uh not just him but
in the hearing they did imply that
people have been murdered to cover up
UFO information in the government and
that he implied aliens are trying to
harm human beings I I don't buy it if if
they're if you can so I'm not even sold
on the con on the possibility of an
alien craft getting from another star
system to our solar system like I'm I'm
not even sold on that but meaning you're
saying they're real they just can't
travel this far yeah I'm not sure that
that you can travel those distances but
that being said even if that's the case
right say we'll give that like if they
have the technology to do that to make
that Journey there is no way human
beings could do anything at all to stop
them if they desired whatever they want
to do we we could not do anything at all
they would be so Advanced so far beyond
our ability not it's not necessarily
true it's it's
assumptive you know there could be
um an alien species that focused all the
technological technological development
into Einstein Rosen Bridges and their
Communications can be lacking you know
their manufacturing could be more
lacking but you know it may be
surprising to another species that we've
so heavily developed communication
Technologies
the assumption that aliens will be like
people like bipeds with hands too second
law of Thermodynamics says that you
can't like that you have to like nothing
is created or destroyed like it's you
the end or the law of Entry I mean like
you're not like all of of
all the evidence is that that things
break down you know the only
thing that that
has been able to expand upon itself and
replicate itself is here on Earth we
haven't seen that anywhere else well uh
there's there's negative entropy in in
you know like matter comes together and
fusion occurs in Stars yeah over time it
has to create more entropy than than
attributes the theory that's confusing
people say you can't get more energy out
of a system than you put into it but
people are assuming that systems are
closed there are no closed systems in
reality everything energy can always
come into you into your area from
further away but yeah I'm just trying to
so you can create systems like Fusion
pulls it in from outside I'm just trying
not to deviate because that that's way
too far off where we were what I'm
saying is in the event any kind of alien
life came to Earth for some reason it is
an assumption that they would be more
advanced than us beyond our recognition
but they could have sent like drone
craft with like a bio-organic machine as
the pilot yeah and with it's not
targeted so as soon as it enters the
solar system just crashes like they
could have it could be done well I don't
think I think we're just trying to fund
space force Russia launched that dog
into space it never came back did it no
of course dog and there's there's also
there's also
um
there's also a theory that
um Yuri Gagarin is that his name was not
the first guy in space he's just the
first guy to come back and the first
guy's base just whoop he's gone you know
whoopsie so look maybe a satellite
crashed and they called it off Earth
Technology with non-human entities I got
here I Googled it my friends what is a
non-human entity as defined by the
Library of Congress
fictitious characters mythological
figures deities legendary characters and
animals with proper names quite
literally
there could have been like a Marvel
comic book if he's trying to manipulate
to distract from the underbite and stuff
because these guys are Intel officers
sorry I'm I'm more inclined to believe
that there if you're if you kept my main
says what's more likely they're trying
to make sure nobody pays attention to
Hunter Biden they've been covering for
the Biden family for decades I bet well
that's a fact or aliens exist I'd be
like well the first one's a fact no
matter what so if you come to me and
tell me this guy's lying about alien to
distract us that just plays into what we
already know and it's probably true also
what about angels and demons
where is that in that definition so it
would be funny if the the craft that
they discovered was like a flaming
Chariot with an angel on it we know I
think there's a lot of evidence if you
want to look at things that are just not
out of out of the ordinary look into
exorcisms and the existence of demons
and evil yeah what do you think exorcism
is anyway it is ultimately call casting
out a demon like is someone having a
seat like a force in the name of Jesus
Christ and they're like they're letting
go of an old Behavior pattern and
they're having like a seizure while it's
happening or something it yeah there's a
physiological reaction absolutely that
is you can see happening I've never seen
have you ever seen one happen I've never
seen one happen but I know people that
have and I've talked to priests that
have done exorcisms and I've talked to
people who've been oppressed by demons
so you don't really see that talked
about a lot at the US Congress but
that's affecting a lot more people than
aliens right now you got an abortion so
there's a lot more to a lot more if you
talk to these hippie leftists they'll
say interdimensional beings you know
like you do DMT and then you see weird
beings and entities that offer you
things and stuff and I'm like crystals
like demons it sounds like you're you're
talking about what people have talked
about for a long time just in a
different way yeah I mean you can invent
sort of a system of what these things
are to you that fits your ideology or
your worldview but at the end of the day
I believe there's God he created human
beings
we have rights there's also angels and
demons demons are Fallen Angels God's a
person angels are persons and humans are
persons and then there's animals so the
the non-human entities and Aliens might
be Angels or demons
possibly I have thought about that
especially those reports from the
military seeing the the you know the the
you know UFO going really quickly and it
seemed faster than any space you know
craft could go like that could have been
maybe an angel you don't know or like do
angels have vehicles
they could if they wanted to that's our
bodies it wasn't Sheamus saying that
angels are not we are our bodies like
physical entities they're not just our
vehicles uh I don't know what Sheamus
was saying but if I understood correctly
like angels are not this like human
beings and angels are very like
different things but angels are not
physical beings it would not be a Bible
Spirit their only Spirit yeah so they
wouldn't recover they can appear as
biologics in order you know to make an
impact that's what happened like
the angel appeared so it looked like a
biologic but that's not a word we use
biological using that because no but I
know it's like so why is he saying that
you know a car accident and we
discovered two biologics like what does
that mean are you telling me that
there's two victims I feel like it's
like they would normally use the term
like remains like that's they call it
biologic like calling it biologic is
weird but like in other contexts they
would say the remains of what we assume
would be a pilot yeah and it's I don't
understand I mean I'm not that I am
trying to look into their brains but
like that's that's the standard way they
describe stuff so I don't know but I
mean biologic is it like is it like the
alien just a paste is it that's what is
it like a goo a bacterial paste that
they worked on on a space station and
then they maybe you know the alien is a
space off-road vehicle it was a it was a
satellite that crashed with uh with with
mold it could have been a snail named
Joe like that's it it's the Russian dog
we found it as long as there's so much
crap going on in the with the White
House I'm not buying plus they lie like
Kareem Jean-Pierre will lie straight
away so why why do we think this guy
won't James Clapper lied under oath to
Congress
let me ask you what what are the what is
the agenda of these intelligence
agencies has it been to expose
secret information to the public or has
it been to protect the bidens and other
corrupt politicians to protect the
government my argument is there's a lot
of incompetency in government and so it
can look like random stuff that doesn't
make sense can look like some conspiracy
that doesn't really make sense but we
think it's targeting someone but a lot
of the times it's incompetency that
would be my argument for a lot of
government bureaucracy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time